The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we're going
to leave off where we were
last time talking
about buffers.
And I'm a big fan of buffers,
actually, and buffers are
extremely useful in my research
because they keep the
p h of things constant.
So if you're going to do any
kind of biology research or
biochemistry research, you need
to know about buffers.
And as I'll mentioned later,
also your body needs to be
buffered appropriately, you
don't want a large changes in
p h in your body or things
won't function properly.
So buffering is very
important.
So let's go over buffers.
So if we talk about an acid
buffer, that's something
that's buffering on the acidic
side of the p h range.
And in that, you want to have
play on both sides.
So if you have a strong acid, it
can be neutralized, the p h
stays the same.
If you had a strong base, that
would be neutralized so the p
h stays the same.
So what happens, you have to
have an acid and its conjugate
base in the mixture to
have a good buffer.
So what the weak acid is going
to do is it will transfer
protons or hydrogen ions to
hydroxide ions that are
supplied by the strong base to
neutralize that strong base
that was added.
So you need to have an acid in
there that's capable of giving
up a proton to neutralize the
hydroxide ion that was added.
You also need to have
a conjugate base.
The conjugate base is going to
accept protons if an acid is
added, thereby neutralizing the
effect of that added acid.
So again, you need a weak acid
and its conjugate base, you
need both to have
a good buffer.
So I've been talking about weak
acids and weak conjugate
bases, so why would a strong
acid and the salt of its
conjugate base not make
a good buffer?
What do strong acids do?
They dissociate almost
completely, and that's not
going to do you any good.
You want to be able to shift
that equation both directions.
So a strong acid goes to
completion is going to drive
it to the right, and for a good
buffer you want to be
able to switch things around
that if you add a strong acid,
then you neutralize that, you
add a strong base, you
neutralize it.
So you need the conjugate to be
effective as a base, and a
strong acid has an ineffective
conjugate base.
It's not good as a base at
all, so that won't work.
So buffers are made up of weak
acids and their conjugate
bases, or weak bases and
their conjugate acids.
They need to be in the
weak range or there's
no buffering capacity.
So let's look at a base
buffer example.
The only difference here is that
a basic buffer is going
to buffer on the basic
end of the p h range.
So here's an equation.
We have a base in water forming
a conjugate of that
weak base and hydroxide ions.
So let's think about
what happens if a
strong acid is added.
Well if a strong acid is added,
then this base, n h 3,
can accept protons from the
incoming acid and make more n
h 4 plus, thereby removing the
strong acid from the solution
and neutralizing the p h.
If on the other hand a strong
base is added, n h 4 plus or
ammonium ions can donate the
proton forming its conjugate
base in water, and again, the
p h remains about the same.
So the base and its conjugate
acid can both react,
neutralizing the p h.
So in the base buffer acid, a
weak base, b, will accept
protons supplied by the strong
acid, removing a strong acid
from the solution.
The conjugate acid of that weak
base, which again, would
be a weak acid, can transfer
protons to the hydroxide ions
added by the strong
base, again,
neutralizing the effect there.
So a buffer is a mixture of a
weak acid base conjugate pair
that will stabilize the p h
serving as a source or a sink
for the added protons.
So that's how a buffer works.
So, I mentioned buffering
is very important.
It's very important
in your blood.
Your blood is buffered in
the range of p h 7 .
35 to 7 .
45, and you have a buffering
pair and a conjugate acid base
pair that's in your blood
that does to work.
So nature has its own buffering
system design to
keep the p h of your
blood constant.
Well what happens if the p
h of your blood changes?
So let me just tell you about
one disease that can change
the p h of your blood.
This is from a vitamin B12
dependent enzyme called
methylmalonic coa mutase, and
this enzyme is your friend.
I think that most of you are
excited about the idea of
having all your fat go to
energy, so you should be all
fan of this enzyme.
So it breaks down from fatty
acids -- you get methylmalonyl
coa, which is converted to
succinyl coa and goes into the
citric acid cycle.
But if this step is blocked,
if there's some kind of
genetic disease associated with
that particular enzyme,
you get a condition called
methylmalonic aciduria.
So this is excreted in the body,
it can't be converted to
the succinyl coa, so it has to
be excreted from the body, and
it has an acidic p h.
And so when it's excreted, it
will actually, there's a large
amount of it, and it can change
the p h of blood.
So even though you have this
buffering system, it can
overwhelm the buffering system
and cause a change in the p h,
which can lead to neurological
disorders and sometimes death.
So they can look for this in
newborns, they can do a test,
and I was -- one of the tests is
-- it's not in every state,
but it is in Massachusetts, so
my daughter, Samantha, had
this test. But they can simply
look at the urine of a newborn
and look at the p h
and whether any of
this is being excreted.
And some infants that have this
condition can excrete
like a gram of this
acid a day.
So it's really large quantities
of acid that are
excreted and it goes beyond
the buffering capacity.
So, I'm going to tell you a
little story and it sort of
emphasizes some of the
importance of genetic research.
So before the human genome
project, scientists were
trying to find the gene to
figure out what was wrong with
these patients that had
this condition.
And here are all
the amino acids
translated from the gene.
This is not a small protein,
that's a lot of amino acids.
And they found that the problem
was right here, or one
of the main problems
is right here.
There's a glycine residue, which
glycine is the smallest
amino acid and that had been
changed to something else and
that led to the disease.
Now I want you to imagine if
you were parents of a small
child and you found out your
child had this condition and
then you had heard that there
were advances, they now know
what caused it, and so, they
went to the doctor and the
doctor said, yes, your child,
the DNA is wrong, and so let's
substitute a different amino
acid for glycine here.
OK.
What does that do for you?
Like why is that a problem?
Well, they didn't know why it
was a problem, they just knew
that it had the wrong
amino acid in there.
And so, the next step was to
try to understand what was
actually going on.
So what happened in this case
was that the vitamin B12
cofactor had changed its
conformation when it bound to
the protein.
And instead of having this sort
of loop structure here,
it had more of a tail.
So this base here had moved
down, and so there was a
different shape to the vitamin
than had been expected.
So when the first structure
was solved of one of these
enzymes, it found that here's
kind of what the vitamin B12
looked like, it had this
extended region which no one
was expecting, and so that had
to fit into the protein.
So this is the domain of the
protein that binds the
vitamin, and it had a large
hole, and you put these
together and that's
great, it fits and
you have happy enzyme.
Well, how do you create a hole
-- nature supposedly abhors a
vacuum, so how do you
have this hole?
Well, what nature did was it put
the smallest amino acids
there are, glycines, right along
here to make room for
this to fit together.
So, what was happening in this
genetic case is that the
switch of a glycine to an
argenine did this to the hole.
So, what people were trying to
do is treat these patients
with extra B12, you give them
injections of it, you have a
lot more B12, and you want to
the B12 to bind and get the
activity back going again.
But really, no matter how much
vitamin B12 you added to it,
it wasn't really going to do
much good, it just wasn't
going to fit.
So instead, there was a
suggestion that instead of
giving the whole vitamin,
perhaps you could just give a
truncated version of the
vitamin, which was
commercially available, and
that that might bind and
restore activity
of the protein.
So this is what was suggested
once you knew what the problem
actually was.
So this is just an example of
a genetic disease, and it's
not that common, but as I said,
it is tested for here in
Massachusetts.
And how knowing something about
what the problem is can
lead to a potential solution.
But for most of you, your blood
is doing just fine, you
don't have a genetic condition
which is pumping too much acid
into your bloodstream, so that
nature's buffering capacity is
working quite well.
So buffers are important.
It's great to have my
important statements
emphasized up there.
We've been rehearsing at home.
OK.
So let's do a sample
buffer problem.
All right, suppose we have an
acid, 0.1 moles of an acid,
and 0.5 moles of its conjugate
base added in
the form of a salt.
And so they're put into water
and diluted to 1.0 liter.
And you're given information
about the k a of the acid, 1 .
77 times 10 to the minus
4, and you're asked to
calculate the p h.
So what do you do?
All right, first, it's always
good to write the equation
that you're talking about.
And so you have acid in water
forming hydronium ions and the
conjugate base.
So here, the acid is giving up a
proton to the water, forming
h 3 o plus and it's
conjugate base.
Now we want to think about what
happens at equilibrium.
So we know how many moles we
have and we know what the
total volume is.
And in this table we should be
using molarity, but the math
here is pretty easy because we
have 1 mole and 1 liter or 1,
and 0.5 moles in 1 liter
or 0.5 for molarity.
And now at equilibrium what's
going to happen, well, when
this equilibrates some of this
will go away and more of these
are going to be formed.
So we have minus x over here,
plus x and plus x over there,
and we add it all together
you get 1 minus x plus x
and 0.5 plus x.
So the important thing to
remember is in buffering
problems, you have the acid
and the conjugate.
So we're used to seeing these
tables where we only have
something over here and it's
all zero on the other side.
But in a buffering problem, you
have things on both sides
from the very beginning.
And that's a really important
point, and that alone, if you
can remember that, will
get you a long way
through this unit.
So you remember that in a buffer
you got to have both an
acid in its conjugate base or a
base in its conjugate acid.
So here we're talking about an
acid in water, it's an acidic
buffer, and so we can use our
k a value -- we want to know
what the concentrations
are at equilibrium to
calculate our p h.
So we can use our k a and we can
set it up, so we have on
the top products over reactants,
and we we're not
including water in this
because it's dilute in
solution and so it's not
changing very much.
And now we can plug in our
values, so we have 0.5 plus x,
x over 1 minus x.
All right, now this is just
written again from the last
slide, we can try an
approximation, which is it
that x is small compared to
1 molar or 0.5 molar.
And so we can get rid of the
plus x and the minus x down
here and just have one x term,
which makes it simpler to
solve, but we'll have to
go back and check that
approximation in
a few minutes.
So making that approximation,
we can calculate x as 3 .
54 times 10 to the minus 4
molar, and now we need to
check that assumption.
Well, you can probably guess
it's going to be OK, because
something times 10 to the minus
4 compared to 0.5 and 1,
that's probably going to
be OK that it's small.
But our assumption here is that
it needs to be less than
5%, and here it's 0.1%.
So you could just take this
value of x, divide it by the
smaller of the two, 0.5 , times
100, and calculate the
percent ionization.
If it's less than 5% you're OK,
if it's more you need to
use the quadratic equation
to solve the problem.
So x here is our concentration
of hydronium ion, which is
great, because then we can
easily calculate the p h.
So p h again is minus log
of the hydronium ion
concentration, and so
the p h here is 3 .
45.
And again, significant figures,
we'll be talking
about this as we go through.
The volume had two, it was 1 .
0 liters, and so we're going
to have two significant
figures after the decimal point,
because the volume was
limiting insignificant
figures.
All right, now let's consider
what happens if some strong
acid had been added
in the solution.
So the volume is still going
to be 1 liter, because the
acid was added in before we went
up to the 1 liter mark.
So strong acids, they
go to completion.
So, if we added 0.1 moles of
that strong acid, it will
react with equal number of moles
of the conjugate base to
form the conjugate acid.
So we can just do subtractions
here.
We don't have to worry about
setting up any kind of
equilibrium, we assume
it goes completely.
So for the conjugate base we had
0.5 moles before, and it's
going to be reacting then with a
strong acid, so 0.1 of those
will react, leaving us with 0.4
moles of the conjugate,
and that's in 1 liter.
So now we have 0.4 molar.
For the acid, we had 1 mole to
begin with, but now we formed
more as they reaction
has taken place, and
so we have 0.1 more.
Now we have 1 .
1 moles again in 1 liter.
So now we can do the
same thing again.
So after this has happened,
after we have added the strong
acid, then a new equilibrium
is going to be reached.
And so we can plug in
this table as well.
So we have 1 .
1 now over here, and 0.4
on the other side.
As equilibrium is approached,
you lose some of the acid as
it reacts with water and ionizes
and you form more of
the h 3 o plus and more
of the conjugate.
So we have 1 .
1 minus x, x, and 0.4 plus x.
So again, the trick here is just
to remember that there is
a reaction with a strong acid
that has been added, and you
need to figure out the new
molarities, and then go back
to your equilibrium table with
those new molarities.
So here we can set up with a
k a again, and do the same
problem that we did before.
And so, we can make the
assumption again that x is
small, try it out and
see if it works.
X turns out to be 4 .
87 times 10 to the minus 4
molars -- so again, it's a
small number.
And so, it turns out to be 1
. -- less than 1% of 0.4 .
If it's less than 5% of the
smaller number, you don't have
to worry about the bigger
number, and so your assumption
is OK, you don't need to use
the quadratic equation.
And so, then we can calculate
at the end that the
p h is now 3 .
31, again, two significant
figures after the decimal
place because of the volume.
So addition of 0.1 moles of
a strong acid changed
our p h from 3 .
45 to 3 .
31.
So we buffered pretty well.
There was a change in p h, we
added acid and the p h did go
down, but not by an
enormous amount.
And so, that's because this
turned out to be a pretty
decent buffer here,
so we didn't have
a really huge effect.
So, those are -- that's an
example of a buffer problem.
So, let's think for a minute
about designing a buffer.
Suppose you wanted to create a
buffer at a particular p h,
what do you need
to think about?
Well, you need to think about
the ratio of your acid to the
conjugate, and you need to think
about the p k a of the
acid, and the p h
that's desired.
So here is a generic equation
for an acid in water, so we
have our acid, h a, in water
forming hydronium ions and our
conjugate base.
And now we're going to do a
little derivation to come up
with an equation that would be
useful to you in thinking
about buffers and designing
buffers.
So, we can write a generic
term for k a.
K a equals products over
reactants, and so we have our
hydronium ions are conjugate
base over our acid.
And now we can take this
term and rearrange it.
So we can pull a hydronium ion
concentration over to one side.
And now we're going to take the
logs of both sides, so we
get the log of hydronium ion
concentration, the log of k a,
and the log of h a concentration
over a minus
concentration, and now we're
going to multiply everything
by negative sign, so we have
minus logs of things.
And I'm just going to move this
now up to the top of the
screen, and we have
this equation.
So what is minus log of
hydronium ion concentration?
P h.
What's minus log of k a?
P k a.
So, we have p h equals p
k a minus the log of a
concentration of your acid over
the concentration of your
conjugate base.
And these are equilibrium
concentrations for that,
because remember, we derived
it from our equilibrium
expression for k a.
But a lot of times when you're
working buffer problems, you
know the concentrations that you
added of these things, not
necessarily the concentrations
of equilibrium.
And if we rewrite this
expression in terms of the
initial concentrations or
original or o concentrations,
then we have p h is
approximately equal to p k a
minus log of the initial
concentrations of your acid
over your conjugate base.
And this is known as a
Henderson Hasselbalch equation.
And people love the Henderson
Hasselbalch equation, and it
can be incredibly useful to you
in solving these problems.
But I'm going to emphasize when
it's OK to use it and
when it's not OK to use it,
because people try to apply it
to everything, and it's for
buffer problems, and people
apply it to all sorts of things
that are not buffer
problems. So I want to make sure
that it's clear when you
can use it and when
you can't use it.
And it's fine to use it and you
should use it when it's
acceptable, but not
at other times.
It's one of the few equations
in acid base, so people get
very excited by it.
All right, so remember that it's
really equal when they're
at equilibrium concentrations,
and this is just an
approximation that we're saying
that those are initial
concentrations.
So when is it OK to say well,
the equilibrium concentration
is more or less the same as
the initial concentration.
And that's true when x, which is
in this particular example
your hydronium ion
concentration, is small
compared to your initial
concentration of the acid and
the conjugate base that you
added to the buffer.
So, and when x is small, then
pretty much, the equilibrium
concentration equals the
initial concentration.
So there's not really very much
change if x is a really
small number.
So, a lot of the time
this is true.
Remember, we're making buffers
from weak acids and weak
conjugate bases, and the
definition of a weak acid is
that it only loses a tiny
fraction of its protons.
It only ionizes slightly
in water.
And a weak base typically only
accepts a fraction of the
protons it can accept.
It's a weak base, so it's
not doing a whole lot
of chemistry there.
So this approximation is
good a lot of the time.
So just you know when you can
and can not use it, we're
going to give a rule and say
it's the same rule as before.
When we say when x is small
or your hydronium ion
concentration is small compared
to the acid or the
conjugate base, when it's less
than 5%, that's what we're
going to call small, so
the same rule we've
been using all along.
When x is small, this
approximation
works pretty well.
And you can plug in your
concentrations right there --
your initial concentrations
not your equilibrium
concentrations.
All right, so let's use
Henderson Hasselbalch and
design a buffer system if
we want a p h of 4 .
6.
And a good rule to remember is
that a buffering solution is
most effective when it's
plus or minus 1 away
from the p k a.
So that's a good thing
too I keep in mind
for research as well.
If you're really far away from
the p k a, it's not going to
be a good buffering system,
and this is a mistake the
people make in the lab
sometimes, so you may run into
that in some of your
laboratory courses.
So we want a buffer
about p h 4 .
6.
So we can look at our ionization
constants of acid,
and of course, we're always
doing everything at room
temperature in this unit, and so
we can look at what p k a's
are of some weak acids, and
acetate, acetate is an easy
buffer to get your hands on,
acetate is quite available,
and it has a good p k a 4 .
75.
So that's great, we can use that
in designing our buffer.
So, acetic acid has the right
p k a, and we're all set, we
can prepare a buffer.
But we'll need to add the acid
and the conjugate, and we need
to know how much acid and how
much of the conjugate to add.
So we can use Henderson
Hasselbalch equation for this.
We're creating a buffer, and so
this is an equation we can
use for buffers.
We know what p h we want, we
know the p k a of the thing
we're going to use, and we want
to figure out how much of
the acid to use and how much
of the conjugate to use.
We need to know the ratio of one
to the other to set up our
buffer ideally.
So we can plug our numbers
in and calculate that.
So, we can rearrange this if you
want so that the unknown
is on one side and we have
to p k a and the p h
on the other side.
And so, we have here our p k a
minus our p h and we get 0 .
15.
Now we need to inverse log and
come up with the ratio, and
the ratio that we want is 1 .
4.
So we want to have a ratio
from our acid to the
conjugate of 1 .
4.
Well how much exactly are we
going to add them, we know the
ratio now, how much are
we going to add?
Well, you could use 1 .
4 molar and 1 molar, for
example, that would have the
correct ratio.
But how do you know if that's
going to be good?
Well, the ratio is more
important than the exact
amounts, however, the amounts
get to this issue of sort of
the capacity of the buffer --
how resistant it is to changes
in the p h.
So if you use too low
concentrations of both, it
won't be all that resistant.
So if you need to have a better
buffering capacity, the
higher concentrations
that you should use.
And you can use Henderson
Hasselbalch then to calculate
what sort of the minimum amount
you use, the minimum
amount to have that
5% rule work.
So in the example I told you
about this condition, the
buffer in the blood was pretty
good, but the acid with so
much that it overwhelmed
buffering capacity.
So if there had been larger
concentrations of the buffer,
that would have certainly
helped in that case.
So the higher the concentrations
you use, the
more resistant to change.
And that's the idea of
buffering capacity.
So, and if you use too low
concentrations, then your
Henderson Hasselbalch equation
won't even be valid.
So we can go back and calculate
what is sort of the
minimum concentrations we need
to use for Henderson
Hasselbalch to be valid
to meet that 5% rule.
So for a p h of 4 .
6, a hydronium ion concentration
is a 2 .
5 times 10 to the minus 5.
And so then if we work our
equation backwards, we want to
be less than 5%, so we have this
over the concentration of
either one of those times
100% gives you 5%.
So the concentrations need to be
greater than 5 times 10 to
the minus 4 moles or you won't
meet this 5% rule.
So at least to be greater than
that and they need to be in
the right ratio.
Other than that you're somewhat
free to decide what
you're going to do with that,
and there may be other
considerations involved if
you're working with a certain
concentration of protein, you
might not want your buffer
concentration to be too high,
it might start interfering
with enzyme assay,
for example.
And often buffers are
somewhere around 100
millimolar, that's
a pretty common
concentration for buffers.
All right, so this slide we're
doing really well.
So we talked about weak acids in
water, weak bases in water,
and I'm trying to convince you
that these are the same as the
salt and water problems. So
we're going to talk much more
about salt and water
in a few minutes.
And I told you about buffers,
so we only have 2
more things to go.
We need to talk about strong
acids in water, and strong
bases in water, and then you'll
have all of the 5 types
of problems to do
the problem-set.
And as I mentioned last time,
it looks deceivingly short,
the number of questions on
them, but the titration
problems are long.
So don't leave those to the last
minute or there will not
be a whole lot of
sleep involved.
So just a word of warning from
the past. Everyone looks and
go, "Oh, this is an easy
problem-set, there aren't many
problems." So, titration
problems do
take a lot of time.
So let's talk about titration,
so that as soon as class is
over today, you can go work
on those questions on the
problem-set.
All right.
So acid base titrations.
How many of you in high school
titrated an acid with a base?
Large fraction of you, OK.
So usually what titration
problems are meant to do, that
you have something known about
an acid or a base, base say of
known concentration, and and
acid of unknown concentration
or maybe unknown molecular
weight, and you're titrating
them out, titrating them
together to find missing
information.
So you can determine
concentration, sometimes you
can determine a molecular
weight.
All right, so here's what a plot
looks like and some of
the key terms involved in
acid base titrations.
So you have a p h on one side,
and then volume of either base
or acid added on
the other side.
So p h versus a volume.
And the actual experiment here,
you have a base that
you're dripping, one drip at
a time supposedly into your
strong acid.
And then you're looking to
figure out when you're going
to reach the either equivalence
point or the end
point, these are basically the
same terms. It's also called
the stoichiometric point, and
often equivalence point is
used as a more theoretical
amount of volume is added,
where as end point is the
experimentally measured.
So we're going to be talking a
lot about equivalence points,
because we have no lab
associated with this course,
so everything will be
theorectical in terms of
these, but they should
be the same.
So, many times you will measure
p h with the p h meter
-- this just shows
a p h meter.
And for those of you who have
done these experiments, this
should look familiar.
And for those of you who
haven't, often what you're
doing when you're dripping
something in, you're waiting
for an indicator dye to change
color as an indication that
you have reached the end
point, and often you're
adding, and it's clear, clear,
clear for what seems to be
forever, and just as you get
incredibly impatient, you
start adding it faster and
you go all the way
to this dark color.
And what you want is this very,
very, very light changed
color that indicates
the end point.
So you usually go too slow and
then go too fast and then have
to do the experiment
over again.
Those of you who know how to
calculate theoretical values
could sit down and do a
calculation first and then go
really fast right until you get
around this point and add
it really slowly, and be
done with lab sooner.
So, we'll talk about how you
do the theoretical value,
which could save you a lot of
time if you ever run across
these labs in any
future class.
So, here are the two curves that
you would see for either
a strong acid with a strong
base, or strong base with a
strong acid.
So if you're titrating a strong
acid with a strong
base, you're going to start
down being very acidic,
because all you have is
your strong acid.
And then as you add in base,
the p h will go up.
You'll reach this point -- s
is for the stoichiometric
point, we also call this, again,
the equivalence point,
and then it'll continue to go up
and then start to level off
a bit more up here.
If you're going the other
direction, you're starting
with strong base, your p h is
going to be high, and the p h
will decrease as you
add the acid.
And then you get to the
stoichiometric or equivalence
point in the middle of
this curve here.
And then as you go down farther,
more acidic, it
starts to level off.
So those are what the titration
curves look like.
So let's do an example.
We're going to have a strong
base being titrated with a
strong acid first. And our
strong base is n a o h, and
our strong acid is h c l.
So let's calculate the p h
at the equivalence point.
Well, let's just calculate
the p h at 5 mils --
I don't know whether it's
equivalence point, actually.
5 mils of this have been added
to the amount of base.
So we have 25 mils of our strong
base at 0.15 molar
concentration, and we're adding
5 mils of our 0.34
molar acid.
So what we want to do is figure
out how many moles of
base we had to start with.
So how many moles of o h minus
-- again, n a o h is a strong
base, so however much n a o h
you add, is the amount of o h
minus you get, and so we just
put in the number of liters
times the concentration
to get moles.
We don't need any equilibrium
table here.
So then we want to figure out
the amount of acid added when
you're adding 5 mils of it.
So again, h c l is a strong
acid, so the amount of h c l
added equals the amount of h 3 o
plus, that's formed, goes to
completion, and so we added 5
mils, the concentration was
0.34 molar, so we have 1 .
7 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles.
So now, the strong acid is going
to react with the strong
base, and we want to figure out
how much of the base is
left, how much hydroxide ion is
left after it reacts with
the hydronium ions.
So it'll react 1:1,
so we had 6 .
25 times 10 to the minus 3
moles, and we added 1 .
7 times 10 to the minus 3 moles
of the acid, so we're
going to have 4 .
55 times 10 the minus
3 moles left.
And now we can calculate the
molarity here, so we have the
number of moles and the new
volume, so we had 25 mils to
the base to begin with.
We've added 5 mils to the acid,
so our new volume is 30,
and so we have our new
concentration.
And now we can calculate p h.
First we'll calculate p o h, and
then use 14 minus to get
the new p h.
So if you were making your own
little titration curve, we
could have volume of acid on one
side and p h on the other
side, and you have
a point of 13 .
18.
That's how much we have after
you have 5 mils added.
So we didn't, in this curve, we
have not measured the zero
point, but we know what one
point after 5 mils of the acid
has been added.
So now let's go right to the
equivalence point -- so the
way I draw it should indicate
that was not
an equivalence point.
So we want to figure out how
much we need to add of the
acid to reach the equivalence
point.
So the equivalence point or the
stoichiometric point means
that you add the same amount
of moles of your titrate as
you had, and so they're going
to be equal to each other.
So if you're adding acid to a
strong base, you've added
enough acid that you now have
equal number of moles to the
number of moles of base that
you had to begin with.
So we know we have 6 .
25 times 10 to the
minus 3 moles of
the base were present.
So at the equivalence point,
you need to have that exact
same number of moles of acid.
So we know the concentration
of the acid we have and the
number of moles we need, and
so we can calculate the
volume, which is 18 .
4 millimeters, or
0.0184 liters.
So what would the p h then be
of the equivalence point?
We're titrating a strong acid
with a strong base, what
should the p h be?
The p h should be 7.
So somewhere around here we're
going to be at 18, so you can
just try to draw a curve, and
here we have a p h of 7 when
we've gone to about 18 .
4 milliliters added.
So when you titrate a strong
acid with a strong base, you
form a salt that's neutral.
Because the conjugates of a
strong acid and a strong base
are not basic or acidic.
They're ineffective as acids or
bases, so you're going to
get a neutral salt.
So if you're doing a problem
with a strong acid and strong
base, it's not a lot of
calculations that need to be
done at this point, you just
need to recognize that your
salt should be neutral.
So now, we can talk about what
happens if you add an extra
milliliter of your acid, after
you've reached that
equivalence point, which is
something that people probably
have done in doing these
titrations not meaning to,
gone well beyond the
equivalence point.
So first we can find out the
number of moles of the strong
acid that we've added extra,
so we added one mil of the
strong acid, and so again,
it goes to completion.
The concentration, the acid, is
0.34 molar times our 1 mil,
so we've added 3 .
4 times 10 to the minus 4 extra
moles of our acid, and
so let's calculate then what the
molarity is that we have
added that was extra.
And even if you don't
have a calculator,
we've helped you out.
Let's just take 10
more seconds.
I think this is a
first, isn't it?
Did I mention it's a
good idea to start
the problem-set early.
So the trick here was
about the volume.
So we had 25 mils to begin
with, then we added 18 .
4 to get to the equivalence
point, and then we're 1 mil
beyond the equivalence point.
And the tricks to these parts
of the problems are to
remember all the things
that have been added
to get to the volume.
So the problem itself is not
very tricky of having just an
acid in water, but the one trick
is in calculating the
molarity, remembering all of the
things that were added to
get to this point.
And so by the end of the
problem-set this should be
pretty familiar to you, but it's
also something that you
want to make sure that you check
on an exam that you're
not making any volume
mistakes.
So again, here are the things
that you want to remember to
add in in calculating this.
And then, if you calculate
the p h of that, you
get a p h of 2 .
1106, so that's down
somewhere in here.
We've added 1 more mill, and
we're at a p h of 2 .
1106, and this can be
a check as well.
If you forgot to add some of
your volume, you might get a p
h that doesn't make
a lot of sense.
So that can be a double check.
Always ask yourself when you
have a strong base and you're
adding acid, before you've
added very much, your p h
should be basic.
At the equivalence point of
a strong acid, strong base
titration, it'll be 7.
And if you continue to add acid,
then you should have a
pretty low p h, you'll notice
the curve drops off pretty
fast. So it should be a dramatic
change in p h by
adding extra of your acid.
So always check your work.
OK, so let's stop there, and
we're going to weak acid, weak
base titrations next time.